[Music]
good evening welcome to day two of the
world science festival and also offer my
congratulations to the nine new Kavli
Prize laureates that were announced just
this morning from Oslo with the
satellite feed to New York at the World
Science Festival and you know I'm not
intimately familiar with the work of
those who won the prize in nanoscience
or neuroscience but I am deeply familiar
with the work that won the prize in
astrophysics and that work as you may
have read online already was the
discovery which was initially announced
in February of the first direct
detection of gravitational waves
absolutely
wondrous discovery Einstein predicted it
a hundred years ago and now we have
finally confirmed that and I'll have
occasion to come back to that discovery
for a brief description probably a
little bit later on but suffice it to
say for now that this discovery really
feeds in to a pattern that we have been
thrilled to watch unfold over the course
of a few hundred years where
careful observation of the world careful
mathematical analysis of the world has
shown us that science has this amazing
capacity to give us deep insight into
the nature of the world the nature of
reality which is which is really just
spectacular there's nobody who would
deny that except maybe for the
Republicans but
no no no no but my point my point not a
stopped at already you no no my point is
that this amazing progress that's been
made over the course of a few hundred
years has then emboldened scientists to
envision perhaps that all of the deep
truths of the world are susceptible to a
scientific explanation some have gone
out to say that in fact the only true
knowledge about the world can be gleaned
through scientific analysis some have
gone further still and described that
everything that we hold dear everything
that's important to us everything that
really makes us human is ultimately
scientific at its core in fact there are
some scientists who've gone out and I
have to say typically it has been
physicists they've gone out even in
public to make really scientific claims
that this sort of hegemony of science
everything is ultimately describable by
science in fact you know perhaps you
know one of the most egregious examples
of that occurred just recently let me
just show you a little clip of this are
the expression of an equation yes yes
that's I would even say that without
this holographic idea math describes how
your particles move how they behave how
they interact you are a bag of particles
governed by the laws of physics
that's a grip that is a great pickup
line now I should say being on The
Colbert Report is not exactly the place
where you can have the most nuanced come
out in your perspective of how the world
works I hope this will be a forum where
my actual views on this will become a
little bit more clear and I've got a
couple of great friends who are going to
join us in this conversation to explore
those kinds of ideas and many that are
related to them so let me now bring them
both on to the stage so first Leon
Wiesel chair is the Isaiah Berlin senior
fellow in culture and policy at the
Brookings Institution he's the author
among other books of the acclaimed
Kaddish he was a literary editor of the
New Republic from 1983 to 2014 is now
contributing editor and critic at the
Atlantic please welcome Leon Wiesel dear
and we are all so thrilled to be joined
by Miguel Nicolelis who is the Duke
School of Medicine distinguished
professor of neuroscience professor of
Neurobiology biomedical engineering and
psychology and neuroscience founder of
Duke Center for neural engineering
founder and scientific director of the
Edmund Lily saw for international
Institute for Neuroscience he's also
founder of the walk again project an
international consortium of scientists
and engineers dedicated to the
development of an exoskeleton device to
assist severely paralyzed patients in
regaining full body mobility so thank
you for joining us
some of the questions that we may
discuss here tonight just to rattle off
a few are we nothing but the physical
processes that make us up as that
ridiculous person said in that clip its
consciousness nothing but the physical
chemical and biological processes in the
brain or is there more to it is
empirical knowledge at the core of
everything that we should believe as
being true are there human experiences
that are simply unsuited for scientific
explanation does the brain experience
give us a misleading view of reality
what defines us and what defines a human
difference so these kinds of questions
which really span art culture religion
and creativity are all fair game for us
tonight
and let me just throw it to Leon to get
us going thank you my friend
I am a militant unreconstructed humanist
who has met many fewer hours in my day
than you clearly do i i am i confess i
am a little bit ashamed at the level of
my scientific knowledge but nonetheless
some of the questions that i want to
talk about that we will talk about
tonight are are not just scientific
questions they exceed the realms of
science or rather the boundaries of the
realms of science is what we're going to
be talking about and what i thought i
would do just to start it off just for a
few minutes is to just stayed a few
beliefs that i have and well then etc so
the first thing i want to say the first
one is just as a general matter that the
question of the place of science in life
is not a scientific question it's a
philosophical question and no amount of
scientific knowledge no amount of math
no amount of data can tell us where to
put in our lives so the experiments and
the and that and the math and the data
that is something that is not a
scientific
and one can they get one gets into this
interesting discussion about what the
word philosophy would mean there but etc
the second the second belief I have is
that we live in many realms that human
existence is comprised of many realms
and that the differences between these
realms are real that is to say the
difference and we can define what these
realms are in various ways but that they
have their categories that are
appropriate to each their methods of
inquiry that are appropriate to each
their the pace at which they're
experienced is different differ as well
and each of these realms may shed light
on each other so that it can be
illuminating to answer a political
question with an observation about
culture or an economic question with an
observation about politics but none of
these realms
none of these no single no one of these
realms can deserves to dominate all the
others and none of the realms can and
none of the realms can be reduced to any
one of them and the attempt to reduce
and all the realms to one is a kind of
intellectual imperialism and a colossal
act of intellectual simplification now
most scientists that I've met are not
remotely guilty of this imperialism
practicing scientists I must say that
they one of the lessons that science
science that obviously doesn't just
teach arrogance it also teaches humility
and I've noticed that about my scientist
friends and so on but there are cases
there are cases in which then that both
the natural certain certain of the
Natural Sciences and certain of the
social sciences have have presumed have
presumed to to the driver's seat in our
explanation of human life in the social
sciences the most egregious imperialist
in my view is economics we now live in a
society in which some of our most
reputed authorities on the subject of
happiness or eeka economists which does
not happiness I must say I know this is
archaic happiness does not seem to me to
be an economic
subject but again I know that's very
old-fashioned we're living similarly in
the in the era in which we're living in
which our culture certainly but also our
intellectual life is increasingly
overwhelmed by data so that everything
is being quantified one of the Imperial
isms that we have to be vigilant about
is the quantification of things that
cannot be quantified one of the
questions that we have to ask as a
culture is what can a number capture and
what can't the number capture and a lot
of the direction look and the quality of
our culture as it develops well I think
will be owed to whether or not we learn
to resist the lure of the easy clarity
and the easy confidence that numbers can
give people about things that cannot be
mathematically measured
I remember once and I used to work for a
magazine called the New Republic and and
once I was walking by where the some
young people who worked there and I
overheard one young person say to the
other I'll never forget this he said
well my friend ran into her yesterday
and she told him that she loves me which
is a really important data point so I
approached there you know I didn't want
to be obnoxious and I said you know I
promise not to pry and forgive me if you
think I am I just need to point out to
you that the fact that she loves you is
not a data point and if you'd like to
discuss this let he came in and we
discussed it in etcetera etcetera I
think you actually said it's not a
[ __ ] data point if I remember the
story correctly you know I got to say
the its it Trump is everywhere but also
there are other examples one can give so
for example consider the physical or the
chemical analysis of a painting right it
is possible you take a painting by shard
to shard down a painting of cherries it
is possible for a chemist to cast all
kinds of light on how those chromatic
effects are accomplished with an
analysis of pigments a chemical analysis
of pigments and so on but if the
question that is being
is why is that painting beautiful then
that chemical analysis of a painting is
not going to be able to answer that
question even though as I say there will
be nothing false about the chemical
analysis of the painting because at some
level all those pigments on Chartres
Dan's canvas are chemicals etc etc but
could you imagine it's already jumping
but could you imagine at some point in
the far future and you go you should
weigh in we will understand the brain
with such exquisite precision and
accuracy that the correlation between
the feeling of beauty the choice of
colors that are being made by an
aesthetic judgment we understand the
physical processes so well that
correlate with all of those things that
yes we'll never say that they are the
act of choice they are the reason why
Rembrandt chose blue or red but we can
say it is just a physical process that
we understand completely well and if we
could look into the painters head we
would actually know that they were
choosing red at that moment and that's
the physical correlate of that choice I
think well I mean sure go ahead as a
neuroscientist if I can get well I mean
first of all I'd like to thank for the
invitation this is wonderful is a
wonderful opportunity to debate these
things and I think we're very similar in
our approaches because even though I
grew up as a scientist recording
brainstorms recording electrical
brainstorms and trying to look into
thousands of neurons and find exactly
what you're talking about the answer the
prediction of a behavior that is about
to happen so far you can do for some
things you can do for instance for motor
acts you can that's reason we can link
these days brains to machines and can
use just electrical activity from human
or animal brains to control directly the
movements of a robotic device yet when
we go to exact the questions that you
are raising I start wondering myself as
a neuroscientist
not that I'm disputing your point the
you know the laws of physics the brain
has to obey the laws of physics but to
some degree certain attributes that came
with the degree of complexity that
evolution endowed us may not be simply
predicted by the same you know
mechanisms that we used to apply to
understand the universe that is up there
because the universe that is between our
ears I dare to say in front of a famous
theoretical physicist is much more
complex it's much more complex in many
domains yes small footmen I would say
that I completely agree with you and the
reason why I do physics is because it is
so much simpler yeah and and I mean that
quite seriously we have been able in
quantum mechanics to understand the
behaviors of systems with a few
particles and we can do that really well
and that's exciting but you give me
something with all of the connections
and particles inside the head there's no
physicist alive it can do anything with
that and I'll just provoke you by saying
that all this beautiful and I'm a big
fan of quantum mechanics and physics in
general although I'm of course just an
amateur but the beauty of it is though
that you guys have done came from this
came from the biology that evolution
produced so I like to say a mere like
that that in what is out here is the
human universe because this is epic
towed by the human brain is a
reconstruction the best we can science
is that in my opinion like news born
used to say is the best attempt we have
that now to describe what is out there
is the best shot yeah that we have a
reconstructing this and is actually
coming out these concepts electrons
quarks fields is all coming from the
biology of our brains wait are you
saying that when we contact aliens and
in the far far future and we asked them
for their view of how the universe is
put together there's a chance that
they're gonna come out with something
radically different from anything that
will discover there cuz they're talking
about isn't backstage I think if I'm
from the 60s so I'm a mr. Spock's fan
right growing up in Brazil
we mr. Spock was a hero you're talking
about the Star Trek guys talk for the
other guy dr. Spock see the both doctors
but I would say exactly that's my point
that if you go to Vulcan in a natural
selection evolution in Vulcan has been
completely different and a complete
different brain has evolved you know
we've complete different properties
mathematics logic science may be very
different the way they express these
concepts and the way they reconstruct
the universe and there is a chance I
cannot deny that there they may come up
with an explanation that may have some
overlaps of ours but maybe completely
different from what we and not
isomorphic not just a different language
you're saying you're saying literally
different but I have to believe that
that if there are Jews on other planets
say that no matter how different their
brains will be and I hope they're very
different that the even if they come
from different biological origins that
each in their own way by their own path
can hit upon whatever is actually true
about the universe and that we do not
need to condemn ourselves to the idea
that the different by our that we do a
kind of biological cosmic relativism
whereby every brain will have its own
truth I think we're going to say they
have a guilt complex that come from a
planet of yours
besides Jews they're brazilians yes
they'll come and say I doubt it let's
try to do the experiment it's a
difficult experiment because you know
they haven't arrived yet but I think we
should be open to this as I think after
what I heard from you I think
neuroscience has to be open to all the
issues that you raised yeah because when
we talk about the brain we tend to as
neuroscientists we tend to you know be
away or try to be away from these big
questions and I think that's time - for
us to open our me to say two things I
think first there is a difference
between neuroscience and the reception
and the use of neuroscience in our
yeah and one of the things that I see
happening that so alarms me is the way
in which more and more people are now
sitting at the edge of their chairs
waiting for the latest bulletin from
neuroscience so they can understand how
to proceed or understand their own rush
you know so you get you get books that
tell you that Proust is a neuroscientist
for example to which my thought is
immediately
well if Proust is a neuroscientist and
I've already read Proust and I don't
need neuroscience or that Jane Austen is
a game theorist we've had that too
similar response similar response so I
think that one of the things we have to
be aware of there's the science and then
there's the uses to which the science is
put I'm generally it's been my
observation that people do not like
living with uncertainty yeah and the two
the two sources the two most reliable
sources of certainty that they can find
are science and religion now the search
for certainty in both of them often
betrays the spirit of both science and
religion but people need they need to
feel that in some way their lives are an
inevitable outcome of something so are
those different though I mean how well -
yeah I think they operate differently
and I think that that's vulgar science
and vulgar religion because obviously
doubt and skepticism is an important
part but both both but but people don't
always describe religion in that way of
course right I mean that's a probably a
distinct view from what most people
envision as an environment in which
faith is meant to guide your perspective
as opposed to some sort of skeptical
quizzical point of view I think there's
no yes no I think I mean this is just a
detour cuz I wanted to make another
point what we're saying but I think that
there is no religious tradition that
doesn't include not just in its depths
but at any one of its sophisticated
levels important elements of doubt
skepticism in other words it is I say
it's a vulgar idea of religion the
belief in God raises as many questions
as it answers except for people who
don't want questions raised and people
have a powerful interest
some people in not having questions
raised they want the matter settled and
they look for as I say for sources of
certainty for sources of intellectual
confidence about their circumstances and
they don't like the feeling that they
are burdened with the full
responsibility of their circumstances
etc etc but the other thing I wanted to
say when we talk about the the painter
about the painter it's very important to
make a distinction I think between
causes and reasons yes I think that an
artist's an artist production of
painting has both it has causes in the
sense that it's some way it was the
product I mean you know the Divine
Comedy was the product of Dante's brain
not just his mind but reasons there's
something else
in other words reasons are the question
of why an artist made certain decisions
both small decisions of execution and
large decisions of conception and
interpretation I don't believe that
those decisions can be explained only in
terms of causes I really don't know I
I'm with you because one of the things I
have been looking lately because of his
interest in largest-scale brain activity
and how he may either determine or
influence you know art and other aspects
is that there was a moment in our
history of art that people just painting
like a photographer reproducing form and
shape in very precise and there was how
an artist was rewarded by basically
reproducing what is out here in great
detail and suddenly at the beginning of
the nineteenth century and that's the
painting I brought from Turner
you know shape he starts being exploded
you know things they start exploding and
the painters they start saying I don't
want to paint what what is out there and
everybody sees equal I want to paint
what I see what comes from me from the
inside
I want to representation and my brains
own point of view that's how I as a
neuroscientist I would put and light the
reflection of light like what we see
here in there is noise torment steamboat
of Turner was the basically this
beginning of the impressionist movement
in which shape
suddenly start to disappear any modern
art he exploded funny enough this
explosion of space is disappearance of
space coincides with the investigation
in physics of the very little and the
very big when you go back to the atomic
atomistic view in all of nature at the
end of 19th century and you come with
you know quantum mechanics and general
relativity and in space in our
conception explodes from the very tiny
to the huge to the whole universe
and I found it very beautiful that these
analogies this this period shows this
correlation in art and in science were
you coming out of these boundaries but I
would say that if you look at that
Turner that whereas it's certainly true
that he was studying the difficulties
and the drama's of perception yeah
itself I wouldn't read it entirely as an
allegory or an expression of his inner
States I think that he would have said
that that painting was what it looked
like
I don't think he would have said just
that it was what it looked like to me
even though he would have been the first
to acknowledge the subjectivity the
partiality of his perspective that's
what I really believe in the same with
the Impressionists the same with all
they were making a they were making a
claim about the difficulty of capturing
perception the extent to which
perception is involved in our
understanding of objectivity but I don't
think any of them were saying this is
just an expression of my brain no but
what I was I was trying to say is that
in my conception of the brain right now
after 30 years in this and going from
different models of the view what we
actually see as a result is this
collision of what is out here and it's
being pinched in the brain and what is
the brains own point of view what if the
brain is expecting as reality and it's
this collision and I remember Picasso
saying when a journalist asked him in
Paris
what was that painting about one of his
cubistic paintings and he said well if I
knew I would not have painted right you
know yeah well you know there's this
before I you remind me there's this
wonderful story about Matisse who near
the end of his life was commissioned to
paint a fresco in a small church
launce in the South of France and a
filmmaker asked for permission to film
him painting and he granted permission
and then when it was over the filmmaker
showed him the film and Matisse was
horrified and didn't want the film shown
and when the filmmaker asked why the
artist said because your film makes it
look like I knew what I was doing no
there is again I think that this whole
thing we're getting at in different ways
about the the the extent to which we can
invoke subjectivity and objectivity and
what the relation you know a march of
sin has this wonderful concept that he
calls positional objectivity meaning
that and what I think it means that
obviously there's no such thing as a
view from nowhere right there is no such
thing as perfect objectivity but the
impossibility of that perspective part
whatever it would be like it would it's
even impossible for us to imagine to
conceive of what it would be like that
does not condemn us to imprisonment
within subjectivity is either
scientifically or humanistic we are
conceived that there is there is some
negotiation between what comes from
inside and what is outside that allows
us to make certain claims about our
representations of things outside to say
that they're accurate or true or deep
etc it says you know what is that can I
just drill down a little bit because I I
love the idea that you describe of the
distinction between reason and causes
and it and it feels right I mean all of
us feel like we make these choices and
and it's more than just the causal
influence of things that are happening
inside us there's something else but is
that real or is that an illusion is that
just the right kind of language in order
to capture a human experience I mean
interested in both of your perspectives
on this but is there anything more
beyond the physical when we're talking
about what's happening up here or is it
just the physical and ultimately does it
all come down to chemistry and biology
and physics or is it more than that now
there are people who spend their lives
struggling with the so-called hard
question of consciousness right I mean
the easy question that most people
describe is look we can understand how
the brain processes information in the
world takes it in is able to generate
behaviors from those stimuli but the
hard part is usually to assess what it
means to feel what it means to actually
sense what's happening out there in the
world and I at one point and still am to
some degree was a complete reductionist
right it is just the molecules and atoms
and the one thing that slightly made me
question that and I still do at some
level is you know this little bear well
Colbert did it too yeah always does but
but there's this old neuroscientist
story about Mary in the room you know
the one that I'm talking about we have
like a I don't know if everyone's
familiar with this I don't know if it'll
be that useful but for me it was a real
ticker in the head when I first
encountered this and we have a little
little video clip to describe this
scenario so you can bring up that that
Mary's room video that'd be great
imagine that in the far far future
there's a brilliant neuroscientist named
Mary who for some reason is confined to
a room in which everything appears in
black and white there is no color of any
sort whatsoever
Mary can study and access and examine
the world outside but it all comes to
her only in black and white
even so Mary is able to reach a goal
that has long eluded humankind
she totally and fully unravels every
last detail about the structure function
physiology chemistry biology and physics
of the brain she knows absolutely
everything there is to know about the
behavior of the brains every neuron
every molecule every atom
she knows precisely what goes on inside
our heads the details of all neural
processes that cascade when we see a
beautiful red rose when we marvel at a
rich blue sky or when we encounter
something in a curious shade gee Mary is
allowed her room and the very first
thing she sees is a plump red tomato now
here's the question from this experience
of the color red will Mary learn
anything new
well she shrug and just move on or will
she be surprised or thrilled or moved or
gained some new insight through this
actual experience of color and if she
does what does that tell us about the
limits of a purely physical description
of the brain and consciousness which of
course I mean that the point of that
story which was raised I guess in 1985 I
think it was Frank Jackson
neuroscientists I mean the idea of
philosophy the idea was if she does
learn something new by virtue of
actually experiencing color or it could
be anything could be love it could be
passion to be anything if the act of
experiencing something tells you more
than just what you learned by
understanding the the physiology of it
then there's got to be something more in
the world than just the processes I mean
is that did did that ever kick your head
the way it did mine when I first
encountered it well I I can describe to
you in a recent experiment that goes
into this line we did in our lab we got
rats about rats and we put infrared
sensors and implant in their heads and
as you know memos cannot attack they
cannot see infrared light because they
don't have photoreceptors for their
wavelength
and it no have temperature sensors that
get you no temperature sensing for
infrared so we implanted those and we
basically put animals in an infrared
universe where they have to track
infrared beams to find sugar water and
they love to go after sugar water but
what we did was to get the output of
this infrared detector electrical output
that describes the magnitude and
orientation of the beam directly into
the touch cortex the part of the brain
that codes for touching and in about
three days adult rats they have never
experienced infrared were touching
otherwise in visible light they were
actually tracking beams of infrared in
finding sugar water just by experiencing
what we don't know because we still
cannot interrogate them but they were
having some sort of tactile experience
and they were able to track that
infrared light so next time we put their
individual cortex because because after
all visual cortex is used to detect
electromagnetic radiation and in six
hours these rats were able to track
infrared light with one detail they
could merge infrared wavelength with
visible spectrum so we had a task in
which half of the message was coming
visible light and half in infrared and
to solve the maze and find the sugar
water they had to combine both of them
and they did so in these are adult rats
adult brains that according to many
theories out of the brain is plastic
throughout life that piece of cortex
would be dedicated just to visible
spectrum or touch and that's what I was
trying to say I was just trying to say
that the old vision that the brain is
just a passive decoder yeah of what is
there I think is gone but that's still
describing a functional response to a
stimulus that a third party has access
to isn't it
no because the cells in the brain when
we look at individual neurons they now
had responses to both tactile and
infrared in a very nonlinear way we
couldn't predict rowdies Narrows would
map that relationship
so they create an internal
representation and which it was not
predicted by the models that the linear
models that we're using to try to
predict that and the animal could make
sense of that but it's all still physics
in physiology no one more absolutely but
the test reason I'm saying but is that
your view I just no no I'm just trying
to say that the reason the brain is so
complex
yeah and although the laws of physics of
course are the basis of its functioning
is there is a self adapting complex
system it's like an orchestra that when
it plays a song at the very moment and
notice produce is already changing the
instruments that produce the next note
and this is a recursive loop there goes
continuously when there are many ways to
play a song there are many ways to solve
and there's no single correct way to
players no no in fact that's another
principle you know and it's I mean I
think I mean just just speaking from my
own neurons I think that only only a
physicalist could have come up with that
question the idea of whether or not Mary
actually learned something new the first
time she saw red yeah so what's your
view though well she learned about the
richness of the visual world yet learned
about she may have felt gratitude about
being alive right she may have been
stimulated by the heat of the color yeah
I mean there are there are lots of
things she learned on that but does that
mean that there's more to the world
beyond yes look look you know we get
into these definitions of reality and if
you--if physicalists want to describe
all these non-physical humanistic things
that the rest of us live for as
illusions then what I would say is fine
but illusions are real - everything is
real even unreality is but but couldn't
it actually when I'm drawing what I
wanted to say no no I think that after I
put it biology can in some biology can
be responsible in some way from my
loving a woman but biology cannot be
responsible for my loving my wife
because the experience of love is an
experience that has reasons and that
that is involved we involved us as self
interpret
beings with desires and so all the
biology in the world
cannot account from my bond with a
particular woman all the biology in the
world and and the only could the
question that really interests me if the
question that we ask is what is the
meaning of human life which is a
perfectly good question yeah my or what
is the human difference let's say yes I
believe that even if 99.9 percent of our
of our lives as animals as creatures yes
can be explained in scientific or
physicalist terms that point 1 percent
is what we mean by the human difference
right and and I want to believe that and
I want you to and I'm trying but I'm
trying but can I just push a little bit
a little bit harder just so I can get it
um I've tried you know what you live
that way I do I do and I live with a
certain kind of tension between my
understanding of how the world is put
together according to scientific insight
and my intuition intuition that
everybody has that somehow that isn't
really describing at all it's the the
point one percent or more than that
that's somehow something else but but
here's the way that I've tried to make
sense of it and the reason I'm bringing
this up is because it seems to resonate
with the description you gave a little
while ago of the distinct realms that
can somehow inform each other even
though they can't be reduced to one
another because one of the deepest
lessons in physics is that we can
understand the universe scale by scale
by scale what I mean by that is look you
know if Isaac Newton had to understand
molecules and atoms and quarks and
neutrinos in order to be able to write
down his laws of motion he would never
have made any progress thankfully he was
able to look out into the world and see
ordinary macroscopic objects rocks and
the moon and he was able to limit his
attention to that ordinary scale write
down equations that were able to
describe those process
and it worked in that environment in
that domain and then as we got better at
examining the world we were able to
penetrate more deeply we did get to the
molecules and atoms and holy cow a whole
new set of equations a whole new
vocabulary needed to be brought forward
the vocabulary of quantum physics and it
works incredibly well at that scale
they're not in contradiction you can get
one from the other so that's a preamble
to the way that I would try to make
sense of what you said which is look you
know what yes so when we're talking
about the human difference when we're
talking about trying to explain say why
one loves their wife maybe it is
ultimately all the physical but the
language the relevant language to use is
not that of quantum physics there's just
a better language but nevertheless it
still is just all quantum physics down
there acting itself out even though that
language offers no insight no there's
another point I think is important to be
made because I think we're in the same
the same camp here is that just because
you have a scientific view or try to
look for a scientific explanation for
this phenomenon you know love creativity
you know faith belief it doesn't mean
that you're devaluing the uniqueness of
the human condition
as a scientist as a neuroscientist I
think one of the biggest missions of
science in my humble opinion this moment
is to bring the uniqueness of the human
condition to the forefront because we
are not machines
we are not just super complex digital
computers everybody talked about
computers have we talked about
technology and I use technology I love
technology and I connect brains to
machines
for a living but I think if I can say
that but no rational would ever come up
with the Internet yes yes but what I'm
trying to say is that I have seen the
last two decades or so with this speed
you know of the integration of
technology in our daily routines sort of
almost not I wouldn't say a devaluing
but putting in the second plane the
uniqueness of our human attributes and
what I'm concerned about is that our
over over experience over immersion with
machines may actually be contributing to
trimming some of this beauty some of
these unique human condition but I've
read your bar write your book oh and and
and I read yours oh thank you in
hardcover it's all free okay but um the
argument that you gave in your book
strikes me as less radical than the
description that might be gleaned from
what you just said so tell me if I'm
wrong what I what I got out of your
argument in the book was that if you
focus on modeling the brain as a digital
computer so in more technical terms like
a Turing machine we need to go down that
trajectory but if more or less you model
as a digital computer then you gave some
convincing arguments that that
ultimately will fail that that's not
what's going on Chancellor but it seemed
quite clear that if you were to go
beyond the domain of digital computers
into more sophisticated kinds of
computational devices maybe
probabilistic Turing machines or things
of that sort then the arguments that you
gave would not be as airtight so are you
really saying that there's more to us
than machines or are you saying that
there's more to us than digital computer
you know the argument of the book was
about digital computers yeah Turing
machines right in fact we finished by
saying that devices like quantum
computers for instance is an open
question we you know we we didn't
approach Ronit Sakura and I didn't
approach daddy issue that what we're
trying to say using as you saw Gatos
incomplete curium and other arguments
even Turing's own original work is that
humans or human brain is a hyper
computer it's something above a Turing
machine and a Turing machine would never
be able to simulate this conversation
isn't that just another kind of machine
it's a more sophisticated machine
is a very interesting question is a very
interesting function yeah
I didn't mean to no no I didn't crowd
worked up a little bit but I think I
think I think our rationale is there
organic organic systems like a brain but
it simply the human brain the primate
brain human brain they they obey the
laws of physics but they get into real
more complexity a level complexity where
you have so many variables interacting
resonating with one another in that you
basically create at a level of complex
where a new type of information may be
produced we're debating there in fact
not just digital information so I
example I gave we're debating was a
classical example in medicine in
neuroscience is the phantom limb
sensation where you have a patient I had
a few where you have an amputation yeah
the patient is fully aware that his leg
let's say was amputated but he's having
a feeling he's having pain on a piece of
the body that doesn't exist anymore no
digital machine would be able to solve
that ambiguity because you can come
forgive me you can come in front of the
patient with the leg amputated and he
would say no no I know that he won't put
it in my leg but I feel perfectly fine
that I'm touching the corner of the bed
with my toe and my too is hurting
because that's what he had a problem
that required reputation so you have
that ambiguity where at the same part
one on one side there is no leg yeah but
the brain is telling him you have your
last she's but I would I would reject
the analogy of the non-physical astana
Tyrael dimensions of human experience to
the fantasy to the fantasy of a phantom
limb seems to me precisely the problem I
mean from where I sit the burden of
proof for me falls not on people who
wish to prove that we're not a machine
but on people who wish to prove that we
are to me it's perfectly obvious yes as
a matter of lived experience right that
a purely mechanistic account will not be
able to properly describe or explain
some of the central experiences of human
life right and so I want you to really
can
any of that's when I go home tonight I'm
no longer troubled by the tension well
look between my understanding that you
and I sort of in that clip are
ultimately composed of ingredients that
are governed by laws were complex
ingredients and complex interactions but
what goes but my friend is why you want
to believe the other why don't you see
you mean in other word that what is the
seduction of
the mechanistic or physical istic
account actually repulsive finds over
together we are you know we are
completely repulsive I mean I think not
you know but I think why you know you
can make it this thing you know there is
science and there is scientism yes there
is biology and there is biology z'm
there is economics and there is
economies 'im the ism is the thing that
makes me nervous the ISM is that
imperialists the extension beyond the I
did that the idea that no it's there's
nothing controversial about saying that
for the past 500 years for as long as
it's existed Michelangelo's David has
been marble has been stone perfectly
uncontroversial and that at every moment
that we look at it it's still stone the
physical it's account of it is always
true it also is incredibly banal and
doesn't tell me terribly much about why
it is that I'm staring at that statue so
scientism is the idea that all you need
to know is that it's stone and the
humanistic critique of that would be
nobody in their right mind would deny
that it is stone yeah
in other words the idea that that that
that that that the scientific the
physical is the material the biological
the chemical the physic you you name it
that all those dimensions are net are at
play I mean that's not under any threat
from any sane humanist
right right but it's not there is the
opposite there is the opposite but isn't
a little bit of a strong man because I
think most of us would totally agree
that if you just describe it
as marble that that couldn't possibly be
enough to answer the questions for why
we're staring at it but if you have a
fantastically rich and nuanced
appreciation of the brain there's gloppy
gray thing that's interpreting the
photons that are bouncing off the
statute then you might you might be able
to give a completely straightforward
scientific account of why it is that
you're staring yeah well that's
scientific it but then you give the
account of how such an explanation would
explain the beauty of the statute yes
that's our on tours of it yeah you know
I mean you know I wish that I could I
wish I wish I couldn't you're the
framework and that you can critique of
it you know that the framework I think
would be you have this biological system
that's gone through thousands and
thousands of years of evolution in order
to be able to have propagated and
survived and therefore it has a certain
biological chemical physiological
physical structure such that when it
encounters certain kind of macroscopic
forms it responds in a particular way
and I could imagine we can't do it but I
could imagine that we one day will able
be able to give an account where we will
say AHA this brain is going to respond
in such a such a way when it encounters
this kind of stimulus right let me just
but that those responses will eventually
be articulated in words and in concept
yes now there is an infinite variety yes
of words and concepts that could be used
to form what we do whenever we see such
things which is uninterpretable yes
right we interpret everything but that
does a very good point because even from
about a large Cavalieri point of view
from my point of view as a
neuroscientist each one of the human
beings that ever lived
leave and will live are unique because
the absolute dysplasia of combinations
of states that you could produce in a
brain yes will get you know millions of
people looking at a Michelangelo and
have a complete different interpretation
and they are feeling a
of what is there because even though
what you said is absolutely correct
evolution in fact I like to say that the
process of evolution is almost like a
copyright protection mechanism for
copying our brains because it was done
through a infinite sequence of random
events that cannot be reproduced you
know even if you could you know rewind
the tape of life Stephane jego said that
if you rewind the tape and let it ring
again we wouldn't be here right so I
think the biology could account for
exactly what you say that the
combinatorial explosion of connectivity
and states that the mind can come up
because the brain has a history each one
of ours each one of our brains has a
history it has a it has built its own
point of view over our lifetime in his
unique but if I replicate that brain
without having it gone through all of
that history right let's be just
fanciful for half an element how if I
somehow was able to replicate it atom by
atom neuron by neuron even though it
didn't have that historical evolution
leading to the form that it currently
has would presumably you would agree but
they would react in the same way is the
brain that went through all they're not
a mathematician but wouldn't that be an
almost like a non tractable problem
because you'll take the age of the
universe to simulate that thing or more
billions of years of simulation because
you're talking about trillions of
parameters they have to be updated in a
millisecond to be able to simulate
otherwise your model will diverge yeah I
wasn't even saying simulate I'm saying
build another biological object oh
that's easy
in Brazil we know how to do that it's
very simple you know so the real
question is is that you could make it
president yeah that we can make it here
I don't know so so so to what extent is
the history vital to the function well I
think the evolutionary history is
pivotal of course we are we are we our
brains are reflecting the evolutionary
history of our species is millions of
years but we also have the ontogeny of
this brain and their life the unique
life of individual with the brain in my
opinion is building its own
internal point of view as we grow up and
there's reason humans have so long of a
time of postnatal development and why we
play so much we are playing scenarios we
are practicing scenarios and we're
building an account of what is out here
and in in my conception of the brain
every time
I am about to look to something I'm
actually seen before I look because my
brain has a hypothesis he has it has an
expectation of what I'm about to see and
is this collusion or this collision I'm
sorry of what is here with this
expectation kind of scientist kantianism
of some kind
meaning that well I don't there is no
such thing as naked sense experience we
actually bring organizing concepts first
in other words we don't look there and
see seven Brown lines is raw sense data
and then look at combine them into a
chair we see a chair yeah and then we
begin to break it down into what the
sensory data are that allowed but but I
think that's exactly why when you say
Beauty when I say Beauty or happiness
when I say something is beautiful it's
very difficult to define because my my
internal definition of beautiful carries
my entire lifetime story my evolutionary
story in the in the salt and pepper of
my previous experiences which are very
different from yours and very different
can I raise a related question which is
the degree to which you know that the
title of the program is Don Weaver
rainbow right so it comes from a Keats
poem this notion that science somehow
pulls things apart and destroys the
beauty and the wonder of it all and you
know Richard Feinman had a perspective
you know great physicists had a
perspective on this just want to get
your sense of it can you show the the
Richard Feynman flower clip I have a
friend who's an artist and sometimes
taking a view which I don't agree with
very well you hold up a flower and say
look how beautiful it is and he says you
see as I as an artist could see how
beautiful this is but you as a scientist
so take this all apart and it becomes
dull thing
and I think that he's kind of nutty
first of all although I may not be quite
as refined as statically as he is but I
can't appreciate the beauty of the
flower at the same time I see much more
about the flower that he sees I mean
it's not just beauty at this dimension
is also beauty at a swallow damaged
I could imagine the souls also the
processes the complicated actions in
sight which also have a beauty the fact
that the colors and the flower of almost
in order to attract insects to pollinate
here is interesting it means the insects
can see the color it's a question why is
it this they know all kinds of
interesting questions which the science
only adds to the excitement and mystery
in the aura of a flower it only adds I
don't understand how it's travelling
thoughts well I look obviously well in
the first place there's no question that
science itself and its discoveries have
been one of the greatest reviewers of
beauty that man has ever experienced or
devised and that's why there are many
scientific results having to do both
with science in the small in the cell
and then you in the galaxy before which
one feels not just a feeling of being
present being present before beauty but
even before the sublime yes which is
another form of aesthetic experience
what I would say about what about
Fineman is that the whole thing begs the
question which is to say that the the
point is not that scientists the good
news is that science is powerless to
destroy beauty even if it thinks it can
that's the good news
so all these physical lists running
around thinking they've they're
murdering to dissect they're wrong
they're dissecting but they're not
murdering except for themselves except
for themselves and a pity on them but
but Fineman begs the question in the
sense that when he says you can
experience the beauty not just at the
flower but also at the cellular level
yeah I would say all right but there
still remains the question of what that
experience of beauty is yeah at any
level yes at any level so and the idea
that the
perience of beauty can be explained
scientifically at any level of
scientific revelation seems seems
imperialistic to me seems incorrect to
me so the the or that he's they mean
that his instruction is don't think that
it's just at the level of the flower we
scientists can see it too and I say yeah
but then I say to him well what exactly
do you think you're experiencing and if
science could give a real account yeah
but if it really could give an answer
well just go with me for half a moment
if it could give an answer to that would
it what impact would that have on your
perspective let's say let's just let's
just say would it matter to you would
you say oh goodness gracious I can no
longer think about the world as I want
you did or is your view just sort of sit
on top of in terms of my own experience
it wouldn't matter one way what would
matter to me is that I don't want my
fellow citizens to believe that they are
nothing but manipulable physical beings
who who lack I don't want I don't want
their horizon for therefore the of the
possible horizon of their experience I
don't want their sense of what of what
their spiritual attainments can be to be
shrunk by the idea that it's all just
matter but does it have to be shrunk
well generally it's had that effect yes
it doesn't need to know it doesn't need
to know I think I think the two views
can can find an all-around big inaudible
I think the definitions of beauty that
we saw only finance description is in
the eye of the beholder right you can
what I think my criticism of the
reductionist view as a scientist is that
yes there is beauty and there's always
an adventure in the intellectual journey
of breaking things apart in trying to
accept because physics was so successful
physics was so successful everybody
thought okay the recipe for success in
other disciplines is just to get their
model and try to apply it to to biology
and other things and the problem is it's
pretty much what you're saying we break
it apart we try to find the fundamental
elements in by
it's very difficult because when you say
life it's not like when you say matter
yes when you say matter you say it's
made of molecules it's made of atoms is
made of nucleons and quarks and strings
but in this a life for biologists it's
not very easy to to come with this
infinity reduction you know reductionist
view of what it is
so our problem is that the science of
complexity in biology is that it's
infancy
we really can't we have very few ideas
and tools to put things together once we
break them apart but you think that the
question of what complexity means and
how it should be interpreted would be
changed or in any way affected by the
discovery of unimaginable degrees of
complexity in other words does it really
matter that the complexity is going to
get greater interfer the search for what
the meanings of that complexity will be
yeah I never thought about it but what I
can tell you is that the way we approach
a complex system today like the brain is
with tools that we approach systems they
are not itself adaptive safe
self-referral and as complex as this
system is because when you talk about a
functioning brain you are talking about
a can exchange of information from
multiple levels from the circuit level
from the cellular level from the
molecule from the quantum level and
you're also talking about a dissipative
system like a pre go gene used to say
with the environment you're exchanging
information in exchanging energy
materials right you have an island of
negative entropy trying to to keep
together not anticipate and the tools
that we have to approach these systems
in my opinion at their infancy and
that's the problem you can break it
apart and in physics works very nicely
but in biology we should be able to put
it together and that's what the
difficulty emerges I think we're sort of
both from different ways arriving in a
similar place it reminds me there do you
know the parable there was a British
philosopher named John wisdom who once
gave a parable created it made up a
parable about the question of whether or
not what's called the cosmological proof
of God's existence the argument for
design
that owing to the complexity that we see
in nature there must be a designer
interest so wisdom made up the following
parable there are two explorers in a
jungle let's say the Amazon jungle and
they're cutting away and cutting away
and cutting away and they enter deeper
and deeper into the jungle and suddenly
they come upon an acre of perfectly
manicured and landscaped lon a
beautifully kept garden so one of them
says it's chance they look like no no no
no there's a garden so the one who says
it's Chan said you know why don't we
stay the night and see if a gardener
turns up so they stay the night of
course no gardener turns up so the man
says I told you there's no gardener so
the one who believes there's a gardener
says no no well that means that maybe we
couldn't see him at night okay we'll rig
up some lights they stay nobody comes
you see I told you it was chance he said
no no it's just a gardener that can't be
seen at night in a light then let's put
up an electric force field they put up
an electric force field nobody comes you
see I told you it's chance he said oh no
all we know is that the gardener is
invisible at night and the light and
immune to the electric force field they
do this on and on until the first one
says to the second you know what let's
go because what you mean by a gardener I
mean by chance you just described a
Swiss garden yes exactly as I had been
there for three years
they look pristine and I never seen the
girl ever well so I got a question from
you from our streaming audience do you
think there's moral worth to taking one
position that you're describing over
another why might it be valuable to
accept the limits of science
well look we haven't talked about the
moral implications of these things and
the reason I didn't bring them up is
because the first thing that matters is
whether or not what we're saying is true
not whether we're saying it's morally
useful or socially that it has any kind
of social utility I think obviously
there are different scientific accounts
of human life that have different
ethical implications yeah you know you
just look at the history of the moral
interpretation of Darwinism for example
yeah in the late 19th century barbarism
was interpreted in an almost fascist way
the survival of the fittest and so on
but then liberal evolutionary biologists
20 and 30 years ago begins
began to argue that actually natural
selection is of course the case but what
we're naturally selected for is not
cruelty but altruism and so you have a
whole literature about the evolutionary
origins of altruism which accepts the
biological evolutionary determinism at
some level but has a totally different
moral implication the real question is
not the first question it has to be not
what are the different moral
implications of different scientific
pictures of life the real question is
does morality need a basis in science at
all at all right you know it is it is as
far as our ethics based our ethics
naturalistic or are they not and there
are obviously different views about this
well the traditional view of course is
that science doesn't have values and
it's just but that's that's a very
simplistic way of looking at thank you
of course yes yeah but that's a very
interesting debate because look at today
what is happening if you read any known
regular book on robotics what is
robotics and artificial intelligence is
doing out there in the economies around
the world in how many very you know in
the next decades or so how robotics may
displace millions of jobs because menial
jobs or not so menial jobs may be done
by by machines so when I read this
literature and I read the descriptions
that try to compare us to machines to
digital computers there I see a
devaluation of the human conditioning
because I start to think okay we are
building these robots to make burgers to
clean floors to do you know this thing
in but we are not stopping to think what
it would mean to have 60% unemployment
around the world these are questions
that we need to bring as scientists you
know as I said I'm I love technology and
I find it that it can be for the
betterment of mankind many things that
we're developing today but some of these
issues have to be brought to society
because society has to wait on them they
have to think about what it means to
replace all these jobs you know in in 20
years there's also the Lord there's also
the question
more generally of whether a purely
physical Astorga t realistic account of
human life is compatible with some
conception of the dignity of the person
it's a very very important consideration
you know it's and and the argument can
be made that in fact it isn't that it is
that it isn't in other words I mean I'm
one of those dinosaurs who still uses
the word soul yeah I know but but if you
call it the soul the self whatever you
know we're some sort of psychosomatic
unity but we are we're compound
creatures in some way I'm speaking
coarsely here yet if one has this
conception one does have to worry about
whether or not the reduction of the
individual to any single dimension of
the person to any single dimension is
compatible with with dignity now I have
to say the reduction it may be also and
I think it's true that not only is the
reduction of the person to the body
maybe not compatible with dignity but
the reduction of the person to the soul
it also leads to extremes of cruelty but
so but I think well that's true but but
I guess my view also is and I think
perhaps one of the beauties of the human
mind which is why all the arguments
about girdle and incompleteness I think
is nonsense when it comes to the mind we
can and we can even rejoice and holding
contradictory ideas inside our head and
I'm I'm fine with having contradictory
ideas inside of this thing even though a
digital computer would crash if this
sort of thing happened I I full well
agree with with much of what you're
saying on the one hand but on the other
hand I say look maybe you're just the
valuing the scientific perspective you
know but I don't necessarily find that
that describing myself in terms of
molecules and atoms and quantum
processes taking place to values mean
why does it enriches me and much the
same way with fine Melissa I forgive me
this is sort of the insecurity that I
find in certain scientists not as in
yeah meet scientism science yes which is
what is threatening to the scientific
analysis of life yeah
when you suggest that the scientific
analysis of life simply cannot account
for all of it yes I don't know anyone in
their right mind yeah who believes that
the scientific analysis of life in
any of its versions is is false right I
mean nobody is arguing you know we are
not animals or that we are not made X
percent of water yeah so what I don't
understand is the need of certain
scientific implements to have it all
right don't under I honestly don't
understand no I totally let me just give
one one video of it one view of it
simply is we we're trying to find the
truth and it's a way the truth and the
truth could well be that all we are is
is the physical and the physical through
the wondrous laws of physics is able to
manifest in all these wondrous ways
where we can't appreciate beauty and we
can love and it can be passionate and it
doesn't devalue it in order to
understand underneath it's just the
physical and it's the urge to know
what's true as opposed to a feeling of
being let me know who sent for a moment
varies I don't feel threatened by as a
scientist by what you said it all I I
actually feel that is a challenge it's a
very good challenge to see if science
can penetrate in realm's that it hasn't
and whether you can be accepted whether
people on a reasonable conversation like
we're having you know could come to a
conclusion that the science has the same
in some of these subjects or not I I
don't feel threatened about the
possibility that there are limits but I
should just make a postscript saying
that I think we are not seeking the
truth I don't believe in the truth I
believe in the best approximation of the
truth that our brains can create because
the deep physicists are just more
ambitious I know but what I think is
important that we when we as you said
when we go out and say what is the
business of science there will be humble
and we have that humility that you said
the ignorance brings on knowledge
because the more we know as you know
very well the more we discover about
this big universe of ours the more we
know that we know very little there's so
much more to know and when we talk about
a human brain
yeah boy believe me we know nothing we
know a little tiny bit
and and we go out and as you said
sometimes say things that we shouldn't
say that we know how this behavior is
created how this option is made and how
we should behave to to be you know
proper human beings and that's
chauvinism there's a scientific
chauvinism that I as a scientist I
cannot accept either
however I do assert that we as
scientists should try to approach these
big questions and come up with the best
shot we have but the thing I would say
is that there are different the first
thing that has to be recognized is that
there are different kinds of questions
yes and that all the questions are not
scientific questions and all the
questions are not philosophical quite
there are different kinds of questions
yes and I think that we have to
recognize that and sometimes when you
recognize it so for example take I don't
know a moment of courage take them you
know a soldier who who throws himself on
a hand grenade and and dies to save the
lives of his comrades science of any
kind
brain science I assume could explain the
operator the how of that that act of
selflessness how you know what was
responding to what what was firing what
wasn't firing I don't know do we
oh well good I feel much more
comfortable about that except I have I
have less excuse for my ignorance did
you but the question of why those men
did what they did is a different kind of
question and what I want to know why why
would they or each of them prepared to
be crucified to protect Spartacus who by
the way was Kirk Douglas yes yes yes yes
but um and when I asked the question why
yeah when I look for reasons yeah right
I have to say science doesn't help me
very much but in May I think in May well
we may there are many reasons why groups
of animals may behave in a certain way
for evolutionary benefit for benefit of
the King for benefit of the offspring
that meaning but it is the case now I'm
just saying that I don't know I have the
answer nobody correct me from
but isn't it the case about in this in
evolutionary biology that the conclusion
to which one comes to that the important
fact are the variations that one winds
up is remarking upon most it's not that
genes determine a similar course but in
fact there's a wide very absolute Lee
okay so then the social behavior is a
very fundamental component of our
species the throughout the various races
right but what I'm saying is that in
cases where well what I'm saying is
first that the variations are not the
answer there the question mm-hmm for me
in other words am I remembered thirty
years ago some evolutionary scientists
published a book trying to prove that
men are basically biologically hardwired
for rape there is such a book accordant
and then you know and I read the book
which was very painful and and as I read
it I thought to myself well even if this
is true the fact is that most men do not
rape right so how are we to explain the
fact that that a genetic instruction is
being defied is been now clearly one has
to conclude that we have the power at
some level you can define power anywhere
you want to act against what some people
would describe as a biological direct
but but certain certain behaviors for
instance the heroism or altruism that
you saw there can influence brains can
synchronize brains to behave as a group
and this mechanism we are trying to
unveil we're studying their studies
trying to look at that well right but
what I'll give the other example way but
I would describe that I mean you're
absolutely right yeah but I would
describe that as the phenomenon of moral
influence and moral inspiration yeah
what I would say is that after the first
man got up the first man who wasn't
Spartacus got up yes and said he was
Spartacus he gave courage to the second
man yes now if you describe it that way
you're just you're in the realm of self
interpreting beings who have reasons for
what they do who have feelings that move
them to now and I don't understand how
that can be accurately described except
in those terms even if all there
netic information was operating as it
was et cetera
but it could be that the way I would
rephrase that and I don't mean to put
words in your mouth so it may not be
accurately phrasing it may be that the
language that you're using the
description that using is so on point
for describing the human experience that
we see in that clip but that doesn't
negate the fact that underneath it there
is a distinct language that uses
different words and different
terminology that nevertheless is also a
completely and fully accurate
description of what - let me just take
one add it out of the realm of emotions
you know if we see a baseball flying
from home plate to the outfield right we
could describe it using the language of
quantum physics we would have 10 to the
23 pieces of data all describing ever
going to a ballgame that's right totally
useless which is my point you'd look at
that and you'd say that's impenetrable I
don't know what that's referring to and
then someone comes on oh that's a
baseball go flying to the app you say
well why didn't you say that and the
point is that language is so much more
economical so much sharper in the
description of what's going on and it
could well be that a version of that
story applies to the title in the
physicalist interpretation of that hit
could explain why the players are
playing the game of why the people are
there to see them play it I don't see
how it could explain that and but for
those reasons that game would not be
taking place yes and that ball or that
physical event would not be taking place
over center field so in other words I
don't didn't obviously it'd be insane to
deny that the physicalist accounts are
not also true yeah in the sense but that
they they describe what it is that they
can describe right but what but I I
would I firmly believe that even the
truest of the physicalist explanations
does hit a limit if we wish to
understand the entirety of the
experience that we're talking and I
think I can agree with that because I do
also agree that it hits a limit in the
sense of
the word that came after limit which for
you is understanding and I do agree at
the level of understanding though it is
useless to give a certain kind of
description however it may also be the
case that there is nothing else in the
19th century actual dis in the 19th
century some of the ideas that I'm
rehearsing were developed by German
philosophers who basically developed a
distinction between explanation and
understanding and you know these were
German philosophers who made a
distinction between that Orvis and shaft
and and Geist efficient shaft and basic
between Natural Sciences and the human
sciences of this science there is not
the right word decent shaft to sort of
knowledge but and that's exactly what
the idea was that there is explanation
and there is understanding yes and the
two are not the same and and the the
message of explanation you cannot do the
work of understanding and the methods of
understanding also cannot do the work of
explanation yeah I think I'd agree and
in physics we call that the run or
Malaysian group I mean there's an actual
technical version of that but we're
scale by scale if we want understanding
we should use certain language and
certain degrees of freedom but in terms
of explanation at all rests on the
fundamental what are you also having
physics phenomena that you can now
compute right phenomena that you cannot
write an equation for and then in solve
that equation you know there are many
reactions many natural phenomena yes dad
you simply cannot form just as you're
saying it's too complicated
yeah you cannot create an equation that
you can solve you know add one but I
just wanted to make a point that what
you were talking about in to my point of
view is a moving border yes aborted that
we don't know where it is very clearly
and it changes over time he's changing
different knowledge gathering exactly
different experiences and but I think
the key from my view the key point of
this dialogue is that that they they are
not mutually exclusive
right I mean that border can exist and
we can recognize the existence at the
border at this moment because of our
lack of knowledge and a thousand years
from the quarter maybe so it doesn't
have this conversation would have a
different quality to it because of all
that we knew at that point
I just jump because we're running a
little bit out of time there's one
subject quickly about what did you vote
the renormalization group yeah sorry I
kind of sound like a bunch of
consultants you have to tell you but I
mean what I want to say is this they
don't completely think so the pluralism
of languages that that seems to accept
the model of the explanation and
understanding yes I think that's
wonderful but what matters is the spirit
also in which physicalists or scientists
accept that in other words sometimes I
hear that acceptance and there's a kind
of scientific condescension to the
language of understanding that's just
well yeah for humanistic creatures tell
themselves because they don't know
string theory or something like that
right and I think that we have to agree
I think we have to agree that if we're
going to accept this double this
doubleness of of description then each
of the realms is as valuable as the
other I would agree with that
I just want to ask you one thing because
it came up a little bit and I know that
when we actually first discussed doing
this program of like last at a Christmas
party and then we began to talk about it
you said you didn't want it to be sort
of a focus like debate on religion which
is totally fine but can we turn to
religion for the last few minutes if
that's okay so we need a few minutes
yeah so so here's here's my question
based on what I've read in some of your
writings and based on what you actually
said earlier your view is that religion
should not you know sacred texts should
not be literally interpreted when we
encounter those texts what we do is we
interpret so is there a difference
between that description of sacred texts
and how you'd say talk about Shakespeare
I think there is I think that religion
my view religion is a natural friend of
science in the following way there the
difference between the ancient and
medieval conception of religion and the
modern conception of religion is that in
the old conception which I hold religion
was essentially first and foremost a
series of propositions about the
universe that are either true or false
right there is a God there isn't a God
there the world was Korea
matter is eternal there is Providence
there is chance but these were
cosmological propositions and religious
thinkers relied upon science as some in
the way that some contemporary
scientists arrive at religious
conclusions sometimes from their own
scientific research relied upon science
to arrive at the truth and their idea
was that whatever is scientifically the
case in other words whatever we know to
be true yeah so that the medieval
philosophers they held the Ptolemaic
cosmology right they were wrong but the
centrality of the Ptolemaic cosmology
for them was simply saying that whatever
we believe to be scientifically true
about the world must also be found in
religious texts because if you are a
believer who believes that the texts
tell the truth and if reason an
experimental research tells you that
this is the truth about the universe and
the and and and the verse says that the
world was created in seven days but
geology tells us that it's so many
cetera et cetera we're going to have to
reinterred the scripture yes because the
scripture cannot lie but what's special
I'll tell you there's a moment there's a
moment it's in one of the most dramatic
moments in all of religious literature
in Maimonides where Maimonides who was a
devout Aristotelian a Tanna devout Jew
and he had the problem but facing the
question of whether or not the world was
created he had the problem that
Aristotle believed that the world was
eternal that matter is eternal where
while in Genesis it said that in the
beginning God
yesso Maimonides went to the painstaking
trouble of logically and rationally
reviewing all of Aristotle's arguments
for the Eternity of matter and descent
to his satisfaction which is saying
something cuz he was a very powerful
mind he came to conclude that Aristotle
had never definitively proved it and so
what he wrote was and this had Jews
burned his book for this in the 13th
century he wrote that we continue to
believe the account in the scripture but
if we could have proved scientifically
that matter was eternal we would have
had to reinterpret the verses to be
consistent with scientific truth but why
not throw the verses away that so I
don't mean that with this
but but throw it special about those
words what's special they're special to
people no no no no please
I mean no what's special those verses
are special to people who believe they
are special yes if you believe that the
Bible is the revealed Word of God and
you seek to be an intellectually honest
individual you have a rough life ahead
of you right there's a lot of work to be
done yeah there's a lot of work when it
would be easier in some way as you say
just to throw them out but it would be
disrespectful yes to people who believe
that what is saying truth to throw them
out and so they are the honest ones are
left with the great task of
reconciliation and that to my mind even
though I'm not going to reveal here my
own beliefs they're not exactly Orthodox
but but to my mind that work of
reconciliation is a very noble endeavor
based upon a very high aspiration to
intellectual integrity but but why what
is the problem of thinking about
religion as a innate property of the
human brain of trying to explain where I
came from where is everything coming
from so I think the divergent fine but I
think biology is that sure but but if
they I have a feeling that religion
thinking probably started the first
moment the first omen aid jump from a
tree walk bipedally and look at the sky
and saw their thing and said boy where
dare come from I need to explain this is
kind something that is part of our brain
is this obsession this craving for
trying to understand you know our
origins our you know the origins of the
universe our origins of our King oranges
of our you know thinking so I'm not a
religion a religion religious person but
what I kind of think is the religion can
be seen as describing for an explanation
this is insane well it's what ladies
remember yes Raley's was looking at the
scar exactly and of course fell
backwards down a well in their
documentation
yeah the paintings you see the paintings
that you see in the caves in
other friends you know let's go Altamira
what these guys were putting their hands
they're painting these animals in
perspective the using the
two-dimensional distribution of the
rocks to create the effect almost of a
creation you know image the attempt by
means of reason to overcome a
mythological or or animistic view of the
world was obviously is obviously one of
the foundations of our civilization and
nothing less my point is simply that not
all religious people are idiots yes and
there's a certain kind of condescension
now many of them are but I have to tell
you I have to tell you I've met a lot of
secular idiots in my lifetime too look
let me tell you one let me give you one
little example of that as we're running
at a time I was invited to a closed-door
gathering a number of years ago that was
I forget the exact name thing was called
like science in the spiritual quest it
was interesting so I went to it and it
was also Nobel laureates you know
national so I thought that we were all
going to sit around the table and and
have nothing to talk about because I
thought we'd all sort of say well you
know yeah there's not much to the and
and amazingly I was the only one who was
coming from a perspective that wasn't
looking to religion and spiritual part
of the truth I mean everybody was meant
to give a presentation that are sitting
there like with my jaw jars as like
Nobel laureates singing Psalms I mean
was a very eye-opening experience to me
because these folks are not idiots and
yet it's a vital part of the world it's
not about a part of mine Brian look what
you happened there's a great hilarious
irony in the recent literature on the
evolution of consciousness right many of
the people who Mark you know there is
many religious people will sometimes
when they can't their minds can't take
them any further and they don't want to
lose those their faith we'll talk about
mysteries yeah its mysterious and people
have mocked them for it and that's sort
of legitimate because mysteries the
invocation of mysteries does not explain
anything it's a way that's like saying
that something causes cancer because
it's carcinogenic right right that
doesn't explain that yeah it's just a
different name yeah but now you have
these diehard physicalists
who were running into real trouble
explaining the emergence of
consciousness real trouble I mean the
real trance there's no question about it
and some of them now call this
themselves the new mysterion's because
what they say these atheists is that we
can't explain how consciousness evolved
from matter but that doesn't refute our
worldview because it's a mystery right -
which I think you know brothers and
sisters you have so forfeited your right
to that word right I mean you know the
Dare secular mystery is fine so but so
has religion with the word miracle no
question because science is making
miracles when we see the levitation ways
yeah when we see the detection of the
gravitational waves come from the
resounding waves of the Big Bang and we
can detect them a hundred some years
after a guy yeah you know with nothing
paper and pencil not a big bang but
rotating black holes yes yep yeah for me
that sounds like the closest of a
miracle one that we can fully understand
himself predicted in which we can have a
result for so it's a a very specific
yeah the human brain point about when
you but there are two ways to use the
word miracle one is in a in a cognitive
rational way yeah do you mean that it is
actually a disruption of natural law no
no no more weight or when we say
something is a miracle that's simply an
expression of our feeling of awe yes we
don't have like telling a woman that you
love her forever you don't you'll never
know you won't be here forever know what
you love her so much at this very moment
that forever is the only word you could
notice no what I wanted to say what I'm
trying to describe is when Einstein said
the greatest mister the universe's that
can be understood actually for me there
is almost a conflict of interest there
because you know the beauty is that we
can think we can create a theory and we
can go there
create an instrument collect this data
and verify their theory using the same
matter that generated that theory yeah
and that's what I call a miracle so I
just want to jump off of that miracle
and that oh you know one of the things
that often people describe
Cendant experiences that really somehow
stand outside of some kind of well you
know you know again I'm saying I've got
two views on all this but it's been a
fascinating conversation but I do want
us to end with some kind of experience
of all and we have the great honour of
having two wonderful musicians are going
to take us out tonight
Joanna cacio Rocca and Pablo la bandera
if you guys can come on out we're just
going to end it with absolutely
beautiful piece of music that will give
us that experience
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so thank you very much seeing other
events
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]